he is the head coach of the dallas
cowboys and the champion head coach of
the packers back in the day for super
bowl 45 on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line mike mccarthy here on the rich
eisen show how are you coach
i'm doing well rich uh thanks for having
me on thanksgiving thanks for coming on
what uh what is sean mcvay feeling like
today do you think mike oh i hope he's
hungover
but
yeah definitely what a great game uh and
i know you just you know talked about
eric weddle's story i mean that's uh
so impressive the the watch and you know
clearly seeing him have that peck injury
and just go right back in there and you
know heck he's calling the defenses
we're in the green dot
and only being there for a couple weeks
so um just
so impressive uh all the way around so i
was very happy to see her get that to
get that championship yeah i mean and
just in terms of how mcveigh is feeling
i guess how
how how was your your feeling after you
win a super bowl super bowl 45 i mean
that's like put put me in in mcveigh's
shoes based through yours is essentially
i guess what i should have asked you
know i remember talking to mike tomlin
about the the uh
the post game press conference how it's
so unfair on the head coach they have to
go to an 8 a.m
press conference the next day and
i don't think my tongue has ever been
that wide you're trying to answer
questions
and uh because i mean i couldn't even
tell you how much
how much sleep i had and mike and i had
a good laugh about it because it's uh
it's it's probably the biggest challenge
you have over the weekend is that press
conference in this morning
right i know and so but yeah because you
got to wake up the next day and you're
standing there with the commissioner and
uh he's dressed nicely and you just
rolled out of bed right isn't that the
way it works or you're not quite even
with the bed how many just you know jump
in the shower and change your clothes
i mean great memories you know obviously
uh just really you know spending it with
your team and in your family afterwards
so many minutes of memory that
uh never gets old but revisiting that's
for sure yeah and interestingly enough
too um mcveigh's from ohio uh in dayton
and he might have made a lot of people
back in his hometown very upset by
beating the bengals i imagine you did
the same thing
by beating the steelers right mike back
in the day very true uh very true uh
i'll say this
i think
still having all my family back there um
you know kind of the common
response that we all
uh heard from the you know the
pittsburgh steeler fans if you know hey
if they were going to lose you know it
was definitely it was the it was the
right team to lose to so you know i
always thought that was a good way of
looking at it you know i would have
preferred to play
anybody else in afc because you know i'm
still a you know pittsburgh steeler fan
at heart i think that's part of growing
up there and that never leaves you you
know um you know my family still roots
for the steelers
you know it's their second team um but
yeah that's uh it was uh it was a cool
experience once it was over but it's
definitely i would i would have rather
played somebody else no doubt mike
mccarthy here on the rich eisen show
head coach of the dallas cowboys i know
you said um after
the the loss to san francisco that you
weren't planning on watching the
playoffs did you did you catch much of
the super bowl or was it just it's just
tough to
watch a game that you wanted to be
coaching in yourself
i mean it's a double-edged sword i mean
it's it's two-fold uh you know i did not
watch the
the divisional round games uh it was
definitely still you know too fresh on
me for for me personally
um but i did watch the uh the
championship games
and i and i
definitely watched the super bowl uh
sunday so you know i had a chance to sit
down with our our youngest son george
him and i watched it and it you know
it's
like i said it's it's painful to be
sitting on your couch on super bowl
sunday i think everybody feels that way
when you when you know you have an
excellent chance to be there
but in the same breath i'm a fan i'm
still a fan of the game of football and
you know i enjoyed the game it was i
thought it was a great game to watch
you know i thought you know both
quarterbacks and you know i was frank i
was very happy for matthew stafford had
a chance to
compete against him a ton in the mc
north and
um just so deserving of a championship
so it's it's nice to see
a quarterback you know you know for all
the players that you know go through
some trials and tribulations and
to come out with a successful super bowl
sunday so i i enjoyed the game i thought
it was a hell of a game and i imagine uh
with the rams on your schedule next year
you are you're hoping aaron donald might
you know uh follow through on uh on
tapping out on his career right coach i
highly recommend it i think they all
should retire i mean
i think i think they're looking at the
right way right like a year off i
imagine to at least take a sabbatical
think about it i i know so i'll ask you
the same question i asked your
quarterback uh dak prescott when he was
in this show studio last thursday how
how often do you think about the way
the game ended against san francisco how
often does that creep into your head
mike mccarthy oh i mean it never leaves
you that that's for sure um you know i
know you know clearly
i mean you know as a coach you're you're
always looking
at you know the details of putting your
players in position to be successful so
you know it's uh you know something we
came in the next day
you know as a staff and and you know
looked at our training tapes and just to
make sure that you know how we present
this moving forward we we got it
you know the details
exactly right because you know you can
only can control what you can control
and you know i think like anything and
the game of football you got to be
careful
in your evaluation process so and and
that's you know frankly that's what
we're doing now everybody was back to
work today
you know we're starting our scheme
evaluation and start building our
installs for next year but yeah i mean i
definitely go through that play all the
time and
um you know what what could we do better
um and you know that's
that's what coaching is all about
because at the end of the day it's not
whether you practiced it or
how many times you did it it's it's the
success of the play and
um and it's all about making the the
players successful and especially
offensively we gotta we gotta make sure
we're putting our quarterback in
position to to be successful uh
especially in those game situation
segments at the
at the end of the game so what would you
have done differently uh other than just
you know uh making sure you got another
shot at the end zone which you didn't
get so what like what would you
change
if well i think it's like anything i
always look at the you know the
application of the training um you know
i learned this as a play caller
you know back in the early 2000s i think
you have to watch on how you evaluate
plays you know every play that you call
you have to
you really have to give it two grades
you know it did it win or did it or did
it lose and you know obviously the fact
that we didn't get that
you know we call a church clock it's
just you know all of our situation um
all our game situation plays you know
have have tags and then and that's we're
in a two play you know last two play
sequence there and so
did the play win or lose you know and
obviously not getting the ball clocked
in time so the play was a was a loss so
but you gotta you gotta take it a step
further in your evaluation and and you
gotta give it a plus or minus you know
it was the scheme
was it favorable for our players to be
successful in that play and that's
that's the part that you know we you
know we've taken a close look on it
because look at because you want to make
sure you're training it
properly you know moving forward and you
know if you you know if you remember the
play
um we were in what we call you know
sideline offense because you know we
didn't have the timeouts and so we were
able to get the ball out of bounds i
think three plays prior to that and uh
san francisco called the timeout
and so they went to a sideline fence
defense so you know schematically
you know the play you know schematically
based on what we had called to get burst
or defense
you know it was a quick throw that was
checked to a draw based off of uh and
eric armstead was the nose we called a
jumper technique
you know where they're you know they're
playing to stop the quick throw
so i think no dak's decision was correct
but we just got to look at the details
of of
what we'll do in that particular
situation and giving us more time to to
get the ball you know to get the ball
spiked uh and get the clock stopped so
you know so we'll look at this you know
the schematic part of it you know we'll
definitely
you know tighten up the you know those
details but you know the reality of is
the play did not we did not execute the
play so uh because you know you have to
get that that last play off and you know
the whole obviously the whole
you know reason for doing that was you
know instead of throwing the hail mary
you know from the 40 plus you're trying
to get it down inside the throat your
line because it puts you in another play
you know another play call which you
know has a higher percentage well uh the
ability to win what do you what do you
make of people who place it right on
your lap coach that the play called in
work it's your fault for letting it go
uh the number of penalties on the day uh
the the snafu after the uh the fake punt
uh where where you try to to to you know
snag into either another timeout or
another penalty out of them how do you
how do you how does that criticism land
in your your world well that's i mean
that's part of being a head coach and
that's part of being a leader and and
you know but
also i think you know going back to your
evaluation process i think that's why
you gotta
you gotta look at every play in the game
you know did it win or did it lose and
and also was it was a scheme favorable
to put the players in position
um you know you look at the you know the
fake pot that was a huge play for us
uh but we were in a you know hurry up
play
you know coming off of that so
you know
obviously they shut it down because of
the attempted you know substitution on
the sideline so i mean you look at all
those details in your evaluation but you
know at the end of the day it's about
winning and and everything we do
here on a daily basis is about winning
when i show up for work every day that's
all that's all i ever think about what
you know how can we make the locker room
stronger the teaching environment better
and you know and that's really what i
keep my my focus on but
you know i think it's like anything
you know criticism comes with the job um
and
frankly the longer you do this you know
it's just you know
the more you know the more more marks
you'll have on it
on you because of it so uh that just
kind of goes with the territory you know
when you lose you know criticism's going
to come
it's going to come heavier and harder
than probably you've ever experienced in
your life when you when you work at the
dallas cowboys you know that's part of
the landscape
so i mean so that's why you just keep
plugging and you know even if you go
back to the last play at the
you know in the san francisco game maybe
you just uh chalk it up to throw two
hail marys in honor of roger stallback
and drew pearson and give it a shot so i
mean i mean you can you can look at all
those things
uh as far as you know your evaluation
but you know it's about making the
players successful and the players have
to have it cleanly um as far as the way
it's repped the way they feel
comfortable with it and you know i've
been at this a long time and
i've seen some great plays on on film on
paper
at practice but if it's not oiled up and
if it's not totally
you know dialed in uh then it's you know
the chances for it to be successful on
sunday are not as high as you want
than they need to be so
i think you just got to stay in touch
that sorry for such a long answer oh
it's all good dallas cowboys head coach
mike mccarthy here on the rich eisen
show okay so uh part of the criticism
coming your way seems to be in a veiled
way from the uh the man who signs your
checks uh to be very honest with you
jerry jones in a story written on
dallascowboys.com
uh was talking about dan quinn coming
back to your fold and mentioning how
sean payton and jason garrett
stuck around uh for a long time as
assistants in dallas because quote
every one of those three coaches have
said they'd love to be the head coach of
the dallas cowboys so my point is that
has in my mind a lot of logic as to why
they might not take a job now rather
than one or wait and see how the cards
go in the future
uh the follow-up question was uh kind of
obvious like what about your current
head coach mike mccarthy and the quote
was mike knows that someday somebody
other than him
will be coach of the cowboys
uh what do you think about that
supposition coach mike mccarthy
oh so we we have an hour correct
the floor is yours the time's yours as
andy reid might say in the media so
what do you think
well i think it's you know i think it's
a number of things i mean i think number
one
you know i think it's you know every
landscape in this league is different
you know i've been
very fortunate to to work at you know
two of the premier organ organizations
um
in pro football
and you know and they're and they're all
different so and and i think clearly
in this you know in this situation you
know the way things are are done here
there's you know there's a a bigger
picture focus and and i've always
frankly just keep it about about winning
and i've always you know kind of taken
uh
taking a blind eye or blind ear to those
things but but that's you know that's
that's not that's not the case when we
work here so i mean i think clearly
uh when you look at those type of
comments you know i think you have to
understand you know the platform where
they come from i mean you know i have an
excellent relationship with with jerry
jones you know we we talk on a regular
basis about everything and anything uh
big picture um you know
tight focus on what we're doing you know
program-wise you know and more
importantly uh you know his biggest
interest is you know the development of
our players especially our young players
so but when i when i look at the you
know the comments i mean the thing about
dan uh you know
dan quinn being here is was very
important to me and our organization you
know i think it's uh
the reality of it is you know dan and i
had visited
long before he ever took a
head coach interview frankly long before
the playoffs even started
you know about uh how happy he
is here you know and and i envy him in
some ways where you know as a head coach
you get pulled away from
the things that really your you were
would help you advance in this league so
i mean the joy that he was having
coordinating uh he's been a tremendous
asset for me
you know personally and professionally
just you know just having another um you
know another individual with the
experience of a head coach so
you know we talked about him staying
here
you know long before he even took it
took the interview now obviously when he
took the interview
and then this you know this this
narrative broke out uh i think it in
reflection to the relationship that dan
and i do have
you know he just said hey man if
i'm not comfortable with this narrative
um you know if if you really feel like i
need to take one of these jobs you know
just be honest with him and and i come
we kind of laughed about it and i just
said dan
10 to 12 years ago i i'd tell you please
get the hell out of here i don't want to
deal with this but the reality of it is
i'm about winning he's about winning and
the best thing for the cowboys
is for dan quinn to be here and no
obviously it was his decision
his alone but i you know i clearly
wanted him to know from
from the start all that that uh you know
i wanted him here because it uh it's
it's in a best interest winning i've
been at this a long time rich
um you know i understand
you know how how hard it is to win a
super bowl
and and so
the best thing for us one of the best
for our opportunity to be
um at the forefront of how we want to do
it here you know it's it's having dan
quinn so
you know as far as what happens next and
all that i think that's really um just
part of the landscape you know jerry's
the owner he's the gm and i mean he's
you know he's uh always taking a 360
degree view of everything and i think
it's like anything in life
you know we have a lot of one-on-one
conversations we we discussed all these
things you know
we um you know i never once felt that i
was not going to be the head coach
moving forward and and frankly i've been
at this long enough that's that's all
i'm focused on and i think the players
the coaches
football operations is is really is my
main hold i'm the leader of this
football team and i'm about winning and
that's that's all i've ever focused on
and that's all i ever will focus on and
um
are these narratives on you usual
absolutely um i've never dealt with
anything like this
um do i wish i didn't have to come on
here and answer questions about it yeah
no no doubt about it i wish we were
talking about something else but
it is part of
it's part of our landscape and um i just
think keeping things keeping things real
and keeping things focused because
at the end of the day it's about the
people that you're in charge of it's
about the people you coach and most
importantly it's about our locker room
and our locker room's about winning i
love our players
uh i love i love what they bring to the
table um i think the
the advancement we made from year one to
end to year two was was impressive we
know we have more to offer
the emotion and the sting of
you know how we lost is real but
in my lifetime in this league it will
make us better and i truly believe that
so it's part of our process
and it's part of our hard hard learning
experience um
but you know i'm not naive to the fact
that you you got to take advantage of
opportunities when you're in front of
you we did a lot we did a lot of really
good things some some great things this
year um but
you know we didn't play our best
football at the most important time in
in our last game and that's and that's
what we have to really focus on moving
forward so uh next time you see jerry
jones uh have you seen him since these
comments came out or do you have an idea
okay yeah i mean all right i'm saying no
he was i haven't seen him since went to
super bowl but okay yeah um all right so
did you i talked to him saturday yeah we
talked we talked about basically so do
you say to him um
today's just not that day that i i
realize i'm not gonna be the cowboys
coach forever today's not that day right
you did you did you talk about this sort
of stuff with him or you just let it you
just go about
your business and let him address it at
some point you know what i mean like
because it is unusual for an owner to
say this sort of stuff certainly about
a coordinator that that you have a great
relationship with and has done a
terrific job i mean so
that's i'm just wondering do you do you
address it directly with him i don't
know we talked about it uh we talked
about dan's situation definitely um you
know we talked about sean payton's
narrative also um you know it's it's
it's been discussed you have to discuss
that with him what is what is it is
anything you can share uh that you have
really the just the conversation was you
know you and i are in this you know back
to back and uh you know it's a
partnership and you know just focus on
what we need to do
moving forward um and you know and he he
made some
you know
personal comments about you know how he
feels about it but you know that's
really for for him and i but uh yeah i'm
very very comfortable with
our relationship and our dialogue i mean
it's uh
at the end of the day uh we both want
the same thing and it's uh
and it's you know to win the world
championship and and hey and definitely
the narratives are unusual um
but at the end of the day i think you
have to
you got to trust the relationships and
the communication and connection that
you have in our in our leadership group
and it's i think we're doing everything
we possibly can to you know
to build a championship team here okay
mike mccarthy i appreciate the time sir
i appreciate you coming on this program
and uh and chopping it up
um and you know you've got a you've got
a a a spot here anytime you want to call
or if you take my call i'm happy to chat
with you as well so i appreciate the
time as always well definitely but let's
uh can we uh change the narratives next
time well i mean i'm not in charge of
the narratives um i guess i am in charge
of which ones i bring up to you
but you know what i'm saying i i i hear
you man and uh you know i know the
season didn't end the way that you
wanted uh i i gotta tell you you know
but you know this the quarterback when
he came in here um he's just the real
deal in every facet in life i saw micah
parsons um on the red carpet of the
honors with his beautiful son
uh unanimous defensive player defensive
rookie of the year candidate i mean
you've got some serious playmakers at
your disposal and i wish you good luck
with that and let's talk before the
draft and uh if not uh after as well
coach definitely i'll see you in
indianapolis okay fantastic thanks for
the call that's mike mccarthy head coach
of the dallas cowboys here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here